all right thank you Rocky Coldwell
Banker premier Realty the sponsor of
this segment is celebrating 25 years in
the valley so Bob and Molly Hamrick know
a lot about the market and have some
great ideas when it comes to selling
your home we are joined by Bob Hamrick
thanks so much for being here hi Kendall
how are you nice to be here it is great
to have you with us the market right now
is neither a buyer or a seller's market
is that correct it's pretty balanced we
had uh inventory that grew in the shift
around the May April May of last year
inventory grew to about 8 700 homes
we're down to about 4 500 homes now
sales have started to pick up so it is
pretty balanced in any case it's a
little more competitive if you're
selling the days of just putting up a
sign and getting five offers right off
the bat probably absolutely it's not the
same yeah so uh it used to be that the
condition of the home didn't matter as
much and it truly does now it's almost
as important as price so causing the
home to be in the absolute best
condition possible is a very much
importance which means money out of
pocket and sometimes people selling
their homes don't have that oh contraire
so correct that is true and so we're
excited to introduce a program called
real vitalized and real vitalize allows
a homeowner to fix up their home to
prepare it to compete with new homes
from a modeling model perspective so
that it sells for the highest price
possible and they're not responsible for
advancing those dollars so we advance
those dollars they pay it back at close
enough right they pay it on the back
side of it but they still end up making
more money than they might have
otherwise the goal is to cause the home
to be very very competitive in the
marketplace and condition is huge today
so to have a home that is somewhat
remodeled new carpeting new paint staged
in a way that causes it to really look
at its best it can cause the home to
sell for the absolute maximum dollar
yeah anybody who sold a home knows what
a headache it is to try to keep your
home looking like it's in model
condition absolutely but those little
things can make a difference they make a
huge difference and sometimes it's it's
disappointing or challenging to be able
to get it in that condition there are
some by homeowners that choose to sell
to what's called an eye buyer and the
eye buyer buys the home in its existing
condition but they put money into the
home and then they sell it for a higher
price we think that the homeowner
deserves that money and so we prepare
the home and fix it up for them so they
get the most amount of money for those
who are thinking about buying and have
been sitting on the sidelines watching
prices go down for a little bit is it
time to jump in that's a great question
and everybody's trying to find the
bottom so everything that we see is that
it is at the bottom we had a lowest
sales price of 425 000 in December of
last year it has been 425 000 all the
way through January and February and
prior to that it was dropping about one
to two percent every month so I think we
found the bottom we may have plateaued
absolutely Bob thanks so much for being
here really appreciate it we want to
thank Coldwell Banker premier Realty for
sponsoring this segment you can give
them a call at that number on your
screen
725-234-2277 or visit their website at
realvitalizelv.com